teams are are critical to grow and not
everybody like most small businesses are
just a solo preneur but if you want to
scale and grow then you have to be able
to work with a team and you have to like
managing people a lot of people don't
like managing people they like just
being by themselves but if you want to
get you want to get a return out of it
and you want to have fun then you have
to you have to want to mentor and lead
and grow and learn to manage a team for
you you might not love digging
ditches uh but you got to connect to the
mission of like hey this is for somebody
this is for somebody's home this is
we're making people healthier we're
we're helping people's lives like you
have to connect to why you're doing the
work